what do you want want to talk to blue
boy Lugo's hear that he wants to talk to
Lugo's what else vagrants care to play
Freya
lucasz expecting me lead the way well
right come on
why I don't get it then stay here think
it over
no the last time I had a Continental
Army ship no when I hauled prisoners
from velan to the slave market in there
now tell me why you're here
any chance you got work for a Witcher
any chance he wants to swim to speak her
up hey lads
strip him bear toss him overboard wait
heard you're headed for the cave of
dreams sure you can't use another sword
or to give us a dozen Griffin to the
master why evens me and the lads up you
and your lads don't know a lick about
monsters Griffin's and wyverns never
share a habitat well maybe our worth a
few silver fine I'll take you away or
he's about to go you're ready we can go
is it far
now our Stones Throw let's gather the
lads and go in we'll know soon if
there's truth to the legends
garol if these are the best warriors in
the crew they'll come with us
you know your oath called the Wolverine
good day and this hair is of Jabberjaw
why's he was so quiet cuz he got no
tongue what happened he lick a frozen
blade no he tore it out cuz he cursed
King brand went drunk lost his power to
speak but kept his honour interesting
customs you got here before we head off
will you tell me about this cave you
could at least tell me what we might
have to fight only you can know that
elders say in the Cave of dreams you
face your greatest fears face what makes
you wake up at night screaming something
that's already been will be or just
might be I do wonder what a monster
slayer fears but we've talked to no
floods stories in hand let's go
the topes of roy 20 now's when we eat
the herbs why would we do that to go on
to where the nightmares are for says the
legend and so we will do what are these
that druid saying
hemlock poppy nightshade and that cheeky
Noah
henbane Oh in for one hell of a ride
fine give him here take it
move Yaris eat up to the last grain I
don't feel no different
how about you move you're asking a muted
opinion you're feeling it mate
come on let's go time to face our fears
a toothpick for a Razorback that's short
of smoke carbs are wrong to your senses
and it's not possible I see you're weary
from the battle sit with me so that's a
mead patella here infectious thank you
my kid we I shot drink with you old man
and I sat called you King get off that
throne while you're still strengthen
your decrepit bones
oof you can talk
you did something what's for Jabberjaw
the first time I left you to punish
yourself and retain your honor but now
now you die like a trollop he is really
Caribbean
I know that
yes you do in our sweet song but I kill
you kill all you plow and seahorse
but you're not
Yara was an accident they all think they
they couldn't clear my conscience
we'll be or nothing boy yeah you pissed
your trousers infected struck the tree
by our home there's three years old I've
shown a hundred times since then today
you pissed yourself before the whole
village the yard Sodom ah
the shame should have punished him
you're a vision
inspector a vision of your job who you
fear because you know you don't remember
what you know you disappoint them
I'm a better warrior than he ever was
prove it give a shite
change of the world want
over my dead body nothing super
get up Garret
I say as I have long I a while your gold
take it get out of my sight what's this
about
my father sent a messenger you were
bound by honor to help me if you
demanded payment take your gold go and
keep away from our lands